>> AND JOINING ME NOW IS THE
FORMER DIRECTOR OF STRATEGIC
COMMUNICATIONS FOR THE 2020
TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
MARK LAWEDER ALSO WORKS WITH
AMERICA FIRST POLICY INSTITUTE,
A TRUMP-FRIENDLY GROUP WELCOMING
THE EX-PRESIDENT TO WASHINGTON
FOR A SPEECH THAT IS SET FOR
THIS TUESDAY.
IT WILL BE TRUMP'S FIRST VISIT
TO WASHINGTON SINCE HE LEFT
POWER IN JANUARY OF LAST YEAR.
MARK, I HAVE TO START BY ASKING
YOU THIS WHY INVITE TRUMP BACK
TO WASHINGTON AFTER HE TRIED TO
PULL OFF A COUP ON JANUARY 6.
>> HE'S STILL THE LEADER OF THE
AMERICA FIRST MOVEMENT.
HE IS THE VISIONARY BEHIND MANY
OF THE POLICIES THAT GOT HIM
ELECTED TO THE WHITE HOUSE.
AND WHEN YOU LOOK AT WHAT'S
GOING ON IN AMERICA RIGHT NOW,
SO MANY PEOPLE ARE CLAMORING FOR
THAT LEADERSHIP BACK.
THEY WANT CHEAP GAS, SOARING
STOCK MARKETS AND NOT WHAT WE
HAVE NOW.
SO TO GIVE VOICE TO THAT AGENDA,
TO LAY IT OUT FOR THE
CONGRESSIONAL MIDTERMS AND
BEYOND I THINK THERE'S NOBODY
BETTER THAN THE FORMER PRESIDENT
TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT.
>> IT'S LIKE HE'S RETURNING TO
THE SCENE OF THE CRIME.
>> HE LEFT OFFICE --
>>TINCITED AN INSURRECTION.
>> HE LEFT OFFICE ON JANUARY
20th.
WHAT IS GOING TO HAPPEN NEXT I
THINK IS ENTIRELY UP TO THE
VOTERS AND THE PRESIDENT AND ANY
OTHER PEOPLE WHO MIGHT BE
GETTING INTO THE RACE.
THE ONE THING WE KNOW THE
POLICIES WORKED.
WHAT WE'RE FOCUSED ON IS REALLY
SETTING THAT STAGE, LAYING OUT
THAT POLICY FRAMEWORK TO GET
BACK TO THOSE WINNING POLICIES
AND PRESIDENT TRUMP IS STILL ONE
OF THE LEADERS IF NOT THE
BIGGEST NAME IN THAT MOVEMENT.
>> SETTING ASIDE THE DEBATE
WHETHER THE POLICIES WORK, THERE
ARE A LOT OF REPUBLICANS, A LOT
OF TRUMP ADVISERS WHO WILL SAY
THE FORMER PRESIDENT EVISCERATED
HIS LEGACY WHEN HE TRIED TO PULL
OFF A COUP ON JANUARY 6.
SO WHY BRING HIM TO WASHINGTON?
>> WELL --
>> ISN'T THERE SOMETHING JUST
WRONG ABOUT DONALD TRUMP SHOWING
UP IN WASHINGTON AFTER WHAT
HAPPENED ON JANUARY 6?
>> I THINK REGARDLESS OF WHETHER
YOU AGREE WITH THE FORMER
PRESIDENT OR ANY FORMER
POLITICIAN, THEY HOLD A CERTAIN
STANDING.
IF YOU WANT TO OUTLINE YOUR
POLICY VISION, OTHER FORMER
PRESIDENTS DO THAT AS WELL.
>> HE DOESN'T HAVE THE SAME
STANDING AS A FORMER PRESIDENT
BUSH OR FORMER PRESIDENT OBAMA.
>> WELL, I THINK THAT'S IN THE
MINDS OF THE MEDIA.
IF HE DECIDES TO RUN, IF HE
DECIDES NOT TO RUN, LET THE
VOTERS DECIDE THAT.
THAT'S ONE OF THE THINGS WE
LEARNED FROM 2016 IS ALL OF THE
PUNDITS ON BOTH SIDES AND ACROSS
THE MEDIA SPECTRUM, THEY WERE
MAKING THE DECISION THIS MAN
SHOULD BE THE NOMINEE OR THIS
PERSON SHOULD NOT BE THE NOMINEE
AND WHAT WE'VE SEEN FROM 2016
WE'RE EVEN SEEING IN THE PRIMARY
CYCLES TODAY THE VOTERS WILL
DECIDE WHO THEY BELIEVE WILL
CARRY THEIR VOICE TO WASHINGTON,
D.C., OR STATE HOUSES.
AND I THINK HAVING PRESIDENT
TRUMP LEAD THAT CHARGE FROM A
POLICY STANDPOINT, LAY OUT --
>> THE PROBLEM IS HE LED THE
CHARGE ON JANUARY 6.
HE CALLED INSURRECTIONISTS OFF
TO THE CAPITOL AND THEY DEFACED,
DEFECATED OUR DEMOCRACY.
>> AND WHEN YOU LOOK AT WHAT'S
GOING ON OUT THERE ACROSS
AMERICA, THAT'S MOTT WHAT
THEY'RE WORRIED ABOUT RIGHT NOW.
I THINK, WHAT, 17 MILLION PEOPLE
WATCHED THE LAST PRIME TIME
HEARING.
THAT'S 90% OF PEOPLE WHO VOTED
IN THE 2020 ELECTION AREN'T EVEN
WATCHING THESE HEARINGS RIGHT
NOW.
IT'S ONE IN TEN.
SO MOST OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
OUT THERE ARE TALKING ABOUT GAS
PRICES AND GROCERY STORE PRICES
AND WORRIED ABOUT THE ECONOMY.
THEY'RE NOT FOCUSED, UNLIKE IN
WASHINGTON, D.C., ON EVERYTHING
THAT HAPPENS WITH THE JANUARY
6th COMMITTEE.
>> ACCORDING TO THE COMMITTEE
TRUMP STAYED HOLED UP WATCHING
TELEVISION MORE THAN THREE
HOURS, UNWILLING TO TELL THE
INSURRECTIONISTS TO GO HOME
BECAUSE THEY WERE, QUOTE, HIS
PEOPLE.
TRUMP NEVER MADE A SINGLE CALL
TO LAW ENFORCEMENT, THE
PENTAGON, EVEN TO CHECK ON HIS
OWN VICE PRESIDENT, MIKE PENCE.
LET'S LISTEN TO SOME OF THIS
RIGHT NOW.
>> ON THE SCREEN IS THE LAST
PHOTOGRAPH OF THE PRESIDENT THAT
NIGHT AS HE WENT INTO THE
RESIDENCE.
AS HE WAS GATHERING HIS THINGS
IN THE DINING ROOM TO LEAVE
PRESIDENT TRUMP REFLECTED ON THE
DAY'S EVENTS WITH THE WHITE
HOUSE EMPLOYEE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAID NOTHING TO
THE EMPLOYEE ABOUT THE ATTACK.
HE SAID ONLY, QUOTE, MIKE PENCE
LET ME DOWN.
>> NOW, MARC, YOU USED TO WORK
WITH MIKE PENCE FOR MANY YEARS.
WHAT IS YOUR REACTION TO THAT?
AT THE END OF THE DAY, AFTER ALL
OF THAT, ALL TRUMP HAD TO SAY
WAS MIKE PENCE LET ME DOWN?
HE DEPARTMENT LET DOWN DONALD
TRUMP.
HE TACTUALLIED STOOD UP FOR THE
COUNTRY.
>> AND THE VICE PRESIDENT LAID
THIS OUT IN THAT LETTER HE WROTE
AND RELEASED THAT DAY ON WHAT HE
THOUGHT THE CONSTITUTION SAID.
OBVIOUSLY MOST PEOPLE TEND TO
AGREE WITH THAT.
AND HE'S SAID MANY TIMES HE AND
THE FORMER PRESIDENT WILL
PROBABLY NEVER AGREE ON THE
EVENTS OF JANUARY 6.
THE BIGGEST THING I TAKE AWAY
FROM THIS, I COMPARE THIS
HEARING TO A GRAND JURY.
WE ARE ONLY SEEING ONE SIDE OF
THE STORY.
WE'RE GETTING THE PROSECUTION
SIDE OF THE STORY AND --
>> KEVIN McCARTHY HAD A CHANCE
TO PUT PEOPLE ON THIS COMMITTEE.
>> BUT WE'RE STILL ONLY
SELECTIVELY SEEING THEIR
NARRATIVE, AND SO THEY INTERVIEW
PAT CIPOLLONE FOR THE WHITE
HOUSE COUNSEL FOR EIGHT OR NINE
HOURS.
WE SEE A FEW SOUNDBITES.
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" HAS WRITTEN
A STORY THAT THE PRODUCER THAT
WAS HIRED TO PUT THIS TV SHOW ON
WAS LOOKING HOW TO FIT THE
SOUNDBITES INTO THEIR NARRATIVE.
IT DOESN'T SOUND LIKE THEY ARE
EVEN DESIGNED TO GET TO THE
TRUTH BUT TELL A STORY THEY'VE
ALREADY SAID.
I READ SOMEWHERE IN THE MAJOR
MEDIA THEY DIDN'T EVEN MENTION
IN THE HEARINGS, AND I DIDN'T
GET TO SEE THE WHOLE THING, THEY
DIDN'T MENTION THE PRESIDENT DID
TWEET TWICE DURING THOSE 187
MINUTES TO SAY, STAY PEACEFUL,
WE'RE ABOUT LAW AND ORDER,
RESPECT THE POLICE.
>> SARAH MATTHEWS TESTIFIED, SHE
WAS ONE OF THOSE FOLKS WHO WAS
IN THE WHITE HOUSE, A WHITE
HOUSE STAFFER AT THE TIME, SHE
WAS TESTIFYING SHE WAS TOLD
TRUMP DIDN'T WANT TO TWEET OUT
THAT STAY PEACEFUL MESSAGE.
THERE WERE OTHER MEMBERS, PAT
CIPOLLONE, YOU JUST MENTIONED,
WAS ESSENTIALLY -- TRUMP WAS
ESSENTIALLY THE ONLY PERSON
INSIDE THE WHITE HOUSE WHO DID
NOT WANT THE INSURRECTIONISTS TO
GO HOME.
EVERYONE ELSE WANTED THEM TO GO
HOME.
DO YOU BELIEVE TRUMP LOST THE
ELECTION?
>> NO QUESTION.
JOE BIDEN IS IN THE OFFICE.
AMERICA WATCHED.
>> BUT, MARC, OF COURSE JOE
BIDEN IS IN THE OVAL OFFICE.
DID DONALD TRUMP LOSE THE
ELECTION, YES OR NO?
>> YES.
HE LOST THE ELECTION.
>> OKAY.
AND WHY CAN'T TRUMP ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT?
THE DAY AFTER JANUARY 6 HE WAS
NOT WILLING TO SAY THAT HE LOST
THE ELECTION.
HE WAS NOT WILLING TO SAY HE
LOST A FAIR ELECTION.
>> WE SAW THE WISCONSIN SUPREME
COURT OVERRULE SAYING THE USE OF
THE BALLOT BOXES WAS OUTSIDE OF
THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS AND IT
WENT TOO FAR.
THERE WERE MANY QUESTIONS GOING
ON IN MANY STATES.
THAT DOES NOT PROVE FRAUD.
I AM NOT MAKING THAT POINT.
THERE WERE EXTRAORDINARY STEPS
THAT DID LEAD TO QUESTIONS FOR
MANY PEOPLE.
>> NO, NO, NO, THIS WAS A FREE
AND FAIR ELECTION.
THAT'S BEEN SAID REPEATEDLY BY
CONSERVATIVE REPUBLICANS, TRUMP
REPUBLICANS WHO HAVE NOW LOST
FAITH IN DONALD TRUMP.
I THINK THE KEY OVERARCHING
ISSUE HERE, MARC, WHY BRING
DONALD TRUMP TO WASHINGTON?
WHY BRING HIM TO WASHINGTON IF
HE'S STILL AT THESE RALLIES,
THESE SPEECHES SAYING THESE
COCKAMAMY THINGS THAT HE WON THE
ELECTION AND IT WAS STOLEN FROM
HIM, WHY BRING HIM TO THE
NATION'S CAPITOL?
>> IT'S MORE AKIN TO THE STATE
OF THE UNION WHERE HE WILL LAY
OUT HIS VISION.
>> WHAT'S HIS POLICY GOING TO
BE?
HOW TO DO A COUP?
>> GETTING GAS PRICES DOWN,
GROWING PEOPLE'S PAYCHECKS,
SEALING OUR BORDER, BRINGING
BACK LAW AND ORDER TO OUR CRIME
PLAGUED CITIES.
THE THINGS ON THE MINDS OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> YOU DON'T THINK THERE'S
SOMETHING CRASS ABOUT BRINGING
DONALD TRUMP HERE?
>> I THINK AS A CITIZEN YOU HAVE
YOUR RIGHT TO VOICE YOUR
OPINION, TO LAY YOUR POLICY
VISION WHETHER IT'S IN NEW YORK
CITY OR ANYWHERE IN THE
HEARTLAND.
HE IS THE LEADER OF THE AMERICA
FIRST MOVEMENT.
>> WOULDN'T YOU RATHER SEE MIKE
PENCE AS THE STANDARD-BEARER?
>> I BELIEVE MIKE PENCE IS AT A
DIFFERENT ORGANIZATION BUT
THAT'S THE GREAT THING.
WE HAVE SUCH A STRONG BENCH.
WE HAVE SO MANY PEOPLE OUT
THERE.
THEY ARE ALL SINGING FROM THE
SAME SONG PAGE WHEN IT COMES TO
THE POLICIES WE HAVE TO DO.
THEY'LL DECIDE WHO THE
STANDARD-BEARER IS OR WHO IS
GOING TO CONTROL CONGRESS IN
JANUARY OF NEXT YEAR.
AND THEN WE'LL HAVE THAT DEBATE.
I THINK THE GOOD THING IS PEOPLE
ARE TALKING ABOUT THE POLICY
SIDE.
WE'LL DEAL WITH THE PERSON WHO
HEADS THE PERSON AT A LATER
DATE.
>> WE HAVE SOME OF THOSE POLICY
SUBJECTS IN THERE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.